[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
hallo und guten abend hinein
zugegeben es kommt einem ein bisschen
komisch vor am heißesten tag des jahres
über die gefahr zu sprechen dass wir im
winter frierend in den wohnungen sitzen
aber es muss sein deutschlands industrie
malt horrorszenarien spricht von einer
existenziellen bedrohung für ganze
wirtschaftszweige
angesichts gedrosselter gaslieferungen
aus russland reagiert auch der
zuständige minister alarmiert robert
habeck plant jetzt eine reihe von
notmaßnahmen und setzt dabei auch wieder
auf die kohle einzelheiten dazu von
klaus brodbeck
genauso dürfte sich ein grüner
wirtschaftsminister sein amt nicht
vorgestellt haben putin dreht am gashahn
robert habeck muss reagieren nun fünf
schnell geschriebene seiten voller
vorsorge ein minister in zumindest
erklärungsnot damit die speicher zum
winter wirklich voll sind das hat
oberste priorität ist es so insofern
also eine ernste lage die die
bundesregierung dann mit ernsten
schritten beantworten wird
kohlekraftwerke sollen so schnell wie
möglich so viel wie möglich strom
produzieren damit möglichst viel gas in
deutschlands speicher geleitet werden
kann das ziel hier 90 prozent füllstand
anfang november die netzbetreiber
bekommen 15 milliarden euro kredit um
trotz steigender preise genügend gas
einkaufen zu können und ein neues gas
auktionsmodell soll unternehmen belohnen
die gas einsparen kritik kommt von
klimaaktivisten dürfen auf keinen fall
den kohleausstieg wieder aufmachen das
ist schon viel zu langer prozess und
schon längst überfällig sondern wir
müssen erneuerbare ausbauen und das
können wir jetzt eben auch sehr schnell
machen und wir müssen einfach drastisch
gas einsparen und dann muss man gucken
wie groß ist die lücke noch doch
deutschlands industrie bleibt auf putins
gas angewiesen das macht nervös die
tatsache dass wir in unserer industrie
hochgradig von energie und an vielen
stellen auch von gas abhängig sind die
macht uns natürlich sorgen nachdem am
anderen ende dieser pipeline jemand
sitzt der offensichtlich unsere logik
nichts zusammen machen hinzu kommt habe
ex plan geht wohl nur auf wenn schon im
winter eigene deutsche terminals für
flüssiggas lng in betrieb gehen quer
durchs parlament werden unterdessen alte
konzepte wieder hervorgeholt von
fracking bis atom
importieren im moment gefragtes gas als
lng und deswegen gehört zur wahrheit
dazu es ist immer noch besser das gas
selber hier zu fördern als es irgendwo
anders fördern zu lassen und dann auch
noch über ein viertel des planeten
hierher transportieren zu lassen
generell sind die kernkraftwerke keine
lösung für die jetzige krise
allerdings wäre es für die nächsten zwei
drei jahre vielleicht sogar die nächsten
fünf jahre bei den akuten energiemangel
durchaus eine option
dementsprechend verstehe ich überhaupt
nicht warum man nicht die
kernkraftwerke in betrieb lässt die noch
lauffähig sind die klimaminister
verlängert die verbrennung von kohle was
für eine vorstellung bis jetzt
ja guten abend herr beck gute nach mainz
der größte fan des deutschen
atomausstiegs ist wladimir putin heißt
es manchmal stadt jetzt mehr
kohlekraftwerke einzusetzen wäre es
nicht eine überlegung die deutschen
atommeiler am netz zu lassen müsste das
jetzt nicht der notfall strohhalm sein
für uns na das war ja eine überlegung
die wir anfang des jahres geprüft haben
die drei verbleibenden atomkraftwerke
laufen ja und wenn man sie hätte länger
laufen lassen wollen hätte man
brennelemente bestellen müssen die wären
dann mit in den nächsten jahres
verfügbar gewesen das hätte uns also im
winter nicht geholfen jetzt gibt's bei
manchen kritikern allerdings auch den
verdacht dass sie an die atomkraft
deswegen nicht mit voller kraft denken
weil es für sie herr beck und für die
grünen allgemeinen der ultimative
tabubruch wäre weiß ich nicht ob es ein
größerer tabubruch wäre als den den ich
heute begangen habe dass wir nämlich
kohle kraftwerke wieder ans netz nehmen
ich versuche mich von dem parteiprogramm
jetzt fernzuhalten und das zu tun was
für die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland am notwendigen getan werden
muss und die atomkraft wäre zu spät
gekommen und wenn man sie dauerhaft
genutzt hätte oder dauerhaft nutzen
wollte verweise ich auf frankreich
frankreich hat 56 atomkraftwerke 29 von
denen sind nicht am netz und die anderen
haben große versorgungsprobleme weil die
flüsse die er zur kühlung gebraucht
werden so nichtige pegelstände haben
also so oder so kurzfristig wie
langfristig scheint mir das nicht die
richtige antwort zu sein die richtige
antwort ist dass wir schnell aussteigen
aus der verbrennung von fossilen
energien und die erneuerbaren mit großer
geschwindigkeit aufbauen wenn man sie
heute hört her hab ich dann klingt das
danach dass wir eine notfallsituation im
winter nicht mehr komplett vermeiden
können dass wir nur noch versuchen
können dass es nicht ganz so schlimm
kommt interpretiere ich sie da richtig
das ist alles noch spekulation das
szenario das jetzt ja zu 60 prozent
eingetreten des nord stream 1 ist und 60
prozent reduziert worden das ist ja
immer einzelne rio gewesen deswegen
haben wir von vornherein darauf
hingearbeitet dass wir möglichst gut
gewappnet sind das ist der ausbau der
terminals das elende
beschleunigungsgesetz das bemühen gas
aus anderen quellen einzukaufen
aber auch das speichergesetz dass wir
jetzt erstmal für die jahreszeit ganz
gute speicherstände haben ist ja
resultat von politischen handlungen und
nun werden wir schauen wie sich die lage
weiter entwickelt man muss aber ja zur
kenntnis nehmen dass putin schnäppchen
weise die gaszufuhr nach europa
reduziert auch um den preis
hochzutreiben
und wir müssen mit unseren maßnahmen
darauf antworten sie versuchen es jetzt
mit appellen sie versuchen es auch mit
ganz konkreten finanziellen anreizen
richtung industrie werden sie denn drum
herum kommen auch verbieten und anordnen
zum essen am ende das werden wir sehen
entscheidend ist dass die gasspeicher
zum winter hin gefüllt sind und zwar bei
90 prozent liegen wie ist das gesetz
vorschreibt und das ist ja nicht aus
versehen und so geschrieben worden wir
sind jetzt bei 57 prozent
nicht so schlecht für die jahreszeit
aber es fehlen eben noch einige und die
müssen wir über den sommer
erwirtschaften
ja das können wir durch einkäufe tun das
können wir durch sparsamkeit tun
deswegen der appell aber eben auch die
maßnahmen die wir jetzt heute ergriffen
haben die gaskraftwerke die für die
stromproduktion benötigt werden aus dem
aus dem betrieb zu dringen jetzt hat der
chef der bundesnetzagentur ihr bei
unserem freitag gesagt selbst mit
knallvollen gasspeichern würde man nicht
über einen harten winter kommen die
gasspeicher wenn sie knallvoll sie und
reichen ungefähr zweieinhalb monate
gemessen an den verbrechen der letzten
jahre noch mal die können ja noch ein
bisschen runter gehen deswegen das
sparen ist wirklich das gebot der stunde
aber diese zweieinhalb monate sind
gemessen für die für keine gas zu führen
und die haben wir ja es kommt der gas
über die lng terminals aus frankreich
aus berlin und aus den niederlanden über
norwegen über italien kommt ja gas nach
deutschland und lebt arbeiten fieberhaft
daran weitere zuvor möglichkeiten zu
bekommen und dann werden wir schauen wie
sich das ganze zusammen rechnet aber es
ist da will ich nicht drum herum reden
ist ist eine angespannte ernste lage und
wenn man sich diese lage anguckt muss
man dann sagen aktuell gewinnt wladimir
putin den kampf um die energie
es war immer klar dass wir bei gas in
einer großen abhängigkeit sind und ich
erinnere daran dass sehr viele ökonomen
am anfang des krieges gesagt haben soll
ist nicht so schlimm dann sollten wir
doch sofort aus dem gas raus diese
stimmen habe ich heute gar nicht gehört
wohl weil den meisten jetzt klar wird
dass die allgemeine berechnung überhaupt
nichts mit der wirklichkeit von
unternehmen von wirtschaftsunternehmen
oder auch von der bevölkerung zu tun hat
und deswegen sind die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben und das schrittweise
vorgehen richtig es ist so dass es eine
art armdrücken ist wobei putin erst
einmal den längeren arm hatte aber das
heißt nicht dass wir nicht durch
kraftanstrengung den stärkeren arm
bekommen können sagt der vizekanzler
wirtschafts energie minister robert
habeck herzlichen dank für das gespräch
und
das gespräch haben wir vor genau einer
dreiviertelstunde aufgezeichnet
unsere nachbarn im westen haben ein
neues parlament gewählt und einen
dämpfer für präsidentin manuell makro
der jetzt für seine reformvorhaben neue
mehrheiten suchen muss die eigene
absolute mehrheit im parlament ist
geschichte was angesichts der
angespannten wirtschaftslage und der
allgemeinen politikverdrossenheit in
frankreich ganz besonders aufhorchen
lässt ist die alarmierend niedrige
wahlbeteiligung fast zwei drittel der
französinnen und franzosen hatten stand
17 uhr keine stimme abgegeben thomas
walde
die spannung in frankreich ist mit dem
schließen der letzten wahllokale um 20
über nicht vorbei sondern nimmt eher
noch zu nachdem was die fernsehsender
aus und hochrechnen erhält das bündnis
ensemble um emanuel makro zwar die
meisten mandate verliert aber deutlich
die absolute mehrheit das neue
linksbündnis mit wirtz weiter die
extreme rechte dritter
wir hatten mehr erhofft und erwartet
regieren heißt sich angreifbar zu machen
man muss auswählen und entscheiden und
auf dinge verzichten das bedeutet
enttäuschung und wir haben eine
bestimmte anzahl franzosen enttäuscht
trat selbst bei dieser wahl nicht an und
darf sich doch als gewinner zählen unter
seiner führung bildete sich zum ersten
mal ein bündnis aus linken sozialisten
kommunisten und grünen die linke will
macros politik verhindern und sieht sich
in starker position dazu dieser große
durchbruch kommt aus der geschichte der
französischen rebellionen und
revolutionen und dieser durchbruch hat
ein gesicht und das ist das gesicht
unseres
kollektivs
ein grund dass frankreich im parlament
eine politische lähmung droht ist auch
das starke abschneiden der extremen
rechten und marine le pen die mehr
mandate als je zuvor gewählt
wir haben das hindernis überwunden dass
unser wahlrecht darstellt dass der
modernen zeit nicht gerecht wird und wir
stellen nun eine sehr kräftige fraktion
das ressentiment national in der
nationalversammlung
emanuele makro hat sich bislang nicht
geäußert mögliche kooperationspartner
auch nicht kurz vor seiner stimmenabgabe
traf auf einen jungen der sich an den
gips signieren ließ es blieb nicht der
einzige beinbruch wir machen heute in
der französischen nationalversammlung
bildet die fundamental opposition von
ganz links und ganz rechts demnächst
einen block gegen macros politik wie es
ihm gelingen soll künftig mehrheiten für
seine reformen und projekte zusammen zu
bekommen bis zur stunde nicht genau
absehbar
ja gerne live nach paris thomas guten
abend muss man kann jetzt etwas tun was
er ja aus deutschland kennt was er hier
bei uns beobachten könnte eifrig
koalitionen schmieden oder wie hat man
sich das jetzt vorzustellen
also dieses konzept des
koalitionsfriedens das kennt man in
frankreich sowie ja gar nicht zunächst
mal muss man feststellen dass frankreich
widersprüchlich war und widersprüchlich
bleibt vor kurzem hat eine mehrheit der
französinnen und franzosen makro ja noch
dem amt bestätigt und nun heute wählt
sie am stärksten und stärkt vor allem
die opposition gegen ihn und zwar die
radikal zur opposition gegen ihn von
ganz links und ganz rechts das macht es
für makro unmöglich wie bisher in der
nationalversammlung seine politik
einfach umzusetzen durchzudrücken er
muss sich neue mehrheiten suchen für
seine projekte etwa für die rentenreform
die ja vor hat wird er bei der
präsidentschaftswahl angetreten ist wo
die her bekommt ist zur stunde
tatsächlich offen die re publica die
konservativen könnten bleiben da haben
sich in den vergangenen minuten einige
geäußert der vorsitzende sagte wir sind
opposition gewesen wir bleiben
opposition das muss nicht in stein
gemeißelt sein das zeigt aber wie schwer
es für macau ist er wird in jedem fall
kompromisse eingehen müssen er wird
abstriche machen müssen und er wird
versuchen müssen auf andere parteien
zugehen und wie sehr ihm das überhaupt
gelingen kann wie die ausgangs chancen
sind wird man erst wissen wenn wirklich
alle stimmen am ende dieses abends
ausgezählt sind danke thomas für diese
analyse live aus paris und die situation
in der ukraine hast du jetzt im
überblick kann ja ganz genau und dort
schauen wir in den osten des landes der
weiterhin stark umkämpft ist die ukraine
berichtet auch heute von schwerem
artillerie beschuss durch russische
truppen in der region luhansk bei der
westlichen ipro soll ein treibstofflager
durch russischen raketen beschuss
explodiert seien nach seinem front
besuch im süden des landes sagte der
ukrainische präsident seelands die in
einer videobotschaft was der ukraine
gehöre werde zurückgeholt
die afg hat ihren parteitag im
sächsischen riesa nach einer hitzigen
debatte ob die europapolitik vorzeitig
beendet dafür stimmten knapp 56 prozent
der delegierten zu zwei stunden war über
eine eu kritische resolution gestritten
worden die unter anderem der
rechtsextremistische thüringer afg chef
hacker eingebracht hatte das gerade erst
neu gewählte führungsduo copala und
weide hatte eine überarbeitung der
resolution gefordert ein delegierter
sprach von einer demontage der
doppelspitze
der waidmann nahe der brandenburgischen
stadt treuenbrietzen breitet sich immer
weiter aus und 600 einwohner aus drei
ortsteilen mussten deswegen heute in
sicherheit gebracht werden die flammen
hatten sich zuvor auf einem gebiet von
etwa 200 hektar ausgedehnt war durch
starken wind die löscharbeiten sind
schwierig weil das gebiet zum teil
munitions belastet ist
20 kilometer entfernt brach heute noch
ein weiterer waldbrand aus neu delhi
in anderen teilen europas ist es seit
tagen ebenfalls ungewöhnlich heiß und
auch hier verheerende waldbrände auf der
griechischen insel euböa versuchten in
der nacht mehr als 100 einsatzkräfte
einen schweren brand zu löschen in
spanien bieten gleich mehrere waldbrände
nordwesten mussten ortschaften evakuiert
werden in navarra bezeichneten die
behörden die lage wegen des windes als
unberechenbar die zunahme von
hitzewellen ist laut experten eine
direkte folge der globalen erwärmung
wie sehr die europäische union in
zeitlupe agieren kann das erfahren
speziell die staaten in denen sie
irgendwann mal den so genannten
kandidaten status verliehen hat häufig
schon vor jahren und dann passierte erst
mal nichts das war dann eher sackgasse
als highway richtung mitgliedschaft in
der eu so wie es aussieht wird auch die
ukraine kommende woche diesen kandidaten
status bekommen wenn alle 27 aktuellen
eu mitglieder zustimmen das wird ihnen
paradoxerweise genau deshalb leichter
fallen weil mit diesem status außer
warten zunächst mal keine konkreten
folgen verbunden sind es ist ein symbol
und auch wenn es um ganz handfeste
wünsche der ukraine geht ist geduld
gefragt wie thomas reichert jetzt zeigt
in einer woche wird deutschland
gastgeber sein eines
hochsicherheitsgefängnisses
auf schloss elmau aus steht der schutz
der ukraine im zentrum und eine so
einfache wie offene frage kann
ausgerechnet das zögerliche deutschland
den westen beisammen halten um putin zu
trotzen
es geht tatsächlich auch darum dass wir
strategisch
von russland in europa
erpresst werden und selber uns
erpressbar machen wenn wir nicht
gegenhalten dagegen erhalten das
versuchte scholz in kiew er ist für den
eu kandidatenstatus blieb bei neuen
waffenlieferungen aber vage unterstützt
die ukraine auch mit der lieferung von
waffen- und wir werden das weiterhin tun
solange die ukraine
versprochen hat deutschland unter
anderem panzerhaubitzen raketenwerfer
flugabwehr panzer versprochen aber noch
nicht geliefert
die ukraine aber bräuchte eigentlich
noch viel mehr sie wird ungeduldig und
ebenso deutschland verbündete
es herrscht immer noch ungewissheit über
das was versprochen worden musst was
wird kosovo ist es das könnte sehr
schnell geklärt werden wenn der
bundeskanzler und die
verteidigungsministerin öffentlich sagen
würden darum wurden wir gebeten das habe
versprochen das haben wir geliefert
das kieler weltwirtschaftsinstitut hat
am freitag neue zahlen veröffentlicht
danach ist bei kaum einem land die
diskrepanz so groß wie bei deutschland
zwischen dem was versprochen also den
oberen beiden und dem was geliefert
wurde ich habe den eindruck dass seite
entscheidungen im deutschen bundestag wo
geklärt worden ist was die strategie ist
dass wir liefern dass wir auch schwere
waffen liefern ja einfach ganze reihe
von bürokratischen hemmnissen haben dass
das verteidigungsministerium schneller
werden muss und es muss dringend
überwunden werden im mai war scholz im
verteidigungsausschuss die sitzung war
nicht öffentlich dass vertrauliche
protokoll liegt dem zdf vor scholz
erklärte bei waffenlieferungen gebe es
keinen absoluten grundsatz und einen
solchen werde er auch nicht öffentlich
benennen dies gelte auch für schwere
waffen
ausgeschlossen sind für scholz laut
protokoll nur moderne westliche
kampfpanzer dazu zählen aldi leopard 1
der marder aber sicher nicht
das ist ein skandal dass schützenpanzer
und auch schwerere panzer in deutschland
stehen die der ukraine helfen können das
kostet jeden tag menschen leben und das
auch eine verantwortung die dieser
bundeskanzler trägt beim eu
kandidatenstatus für die ukraine dagegen
ist stolz wie klare allerdings hier
dafür zu sein kostet erstmal auch wenig
bei waffen geht es um tage oder wochen
ein beitritt kann jahre dauern
reden wir mit manfred weber er ist chef
der konservativen evp-fraktion im
europäischen parlament schön dass sie
bei uns sind genannter weber
genommen dass sie was es gibt kandidaten
die verharren seit jahren fast
jahrzehnten auf diesem kandidatenstatus
kommen nicht voran was muss die ukraine
tun damit ihr das nicht passiert
die ukraine ist heute im krieg im
kriegszustand deshalb braucht man
erwarten dass dabei tritt die
vollmitgliedschaft dann wirklich schnell
um die ecke kommt aber das wissen die
ukraine auch das ist ein symbolischer
schritt aber es ist ein extrem wichtiger
symbolischer schritt selenz gehört bei
uns im europäischen parlament die frage
formuliert ist es wert zu kämpfen und
wir europäer können darauf eine
antworten ja der kampf ist es wert für
freiheit demokratie und rechtsstaat
einzutreten und der haupt europäische
perspektive das ist das was diese woche
passiert und ich bin froh das makro
draghi clausen es unter olaf scholz dass
ich jetzt klar bekannt haben sie sagen
richtig die ukraine ist ein land im
krieg welche konkreten folgen hat denn
dann so einen kandidatenstatus wie kann
dieser status allein der ukraine jetzt
in der aktuellen situation helfen
wir haben doch zu beginn des krieges
schon erlebt wie wichtig die motivation
ist der einsatzbereitschaft wir waren ja
alle überrascht von dem mut der menschen
in der ukraine irland und auch ihre
werte zu verteidigen und deshalb ist
dieses symbol wirklich wichtig darüber
hinaus brauchen wir aber weitergehende
schritte sie haben es im vorbericht
deutlich gemacht die waffenlieferungen
sind skandalös dass die deutschen
zusagen nicht in der ukraine ankommen
nicht so schnell wie möglich jetzt
aktuell werden dort entschieden ob putin
gewinn aber nicht gewinnen deswegen
brauchen die ukraine jetzt die waffen
wir müssen gleich in wirtschaftlich
unterstützen man muss sich vorstellen
die ukraine den geht schlicht das geld
aus in ein land dessen krieges müssen
auch renten bezahlt werden deswegen ist
die wirtschaftliche die finanzielle
unterstützung für den staat wichtig und
als zwischenschritt hin zur
vollmitgliedschaft wünsche ich mir auch
dass wir wirtschaftlich enger
kooperieren der ukraine anbieten
mitglied des währungs des
wirtschaftsraums der europäischen
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft zu werden um
damit investitionen einzusetzen jetzt
kann man in der ukraine bereits sehen
wie der präsident vor öffentlichen
gebäuden europa fahren hat wissen lassen
die wen da tatsächlich bereits überall
wenn man sich den präsidenten seelands
kreiert so ansieht und auch seine pr
arbeit in aller welt ist ja wohl kaum
anzunehmen dass er zufrieden damit ist
jetzt erst mal als als kandidat gepackt
zu werden quasi und zwar über jahre
unterschätzen sie nicht die
frage wie die wie schnell die ukraine
dann eine perspektive wirklich bekommt
bekommt vollmitglied zu werden liegt
dann in der hand der ukraine und ich
habe mit vielen politikern mit vielen
freunden ukraine gespräche geführt und
ich bin überzeugt dass es wenn jetzt
wieder wenn es wieder zufrieden kommt
hoffentlich bald wenn es zu stabilität
kommt dem land dann ist die ukraine mehr
als alle anderen europäischen staaten
die derzeit in der warteschleife sich
befinden bereit zu inneren reformen die
wissen die zahlen tagtäglich dafür was
es bedeuten kann eben europäer zu sein
in freiheit demokratie und rechtsstaat
leben zu dürfen und die innere kraft die
die sehe ich bei den ukrainern weber
worauf ich hinaus wollte ist das ja
jeder angriff auf die ukraine dann
künftig ein angriff auf einen eu
kandidaten start sein wird das kann es
kann auch enormen öffentlichen druck
auslösen wir erleben das ja aktuell
bereits ist denn denkbar dass am ende
die ukraine schneller in der eu ist als
alle meinen jetzt
ich glaube dass das weniger mit der
frage der das vollmitgliedschaft oder
nicht vollmitgliedschaft zu tun hat weil
schon heute müssen wir uns bewusst
machen dass die ukraine unseren kampf
kämpfte unsere freiheit putin würden
nicht nachgeben wenn er gewinnt oder
wenn er denn don was gewinn der wird
weitermachen so wie es die letzten
jahrzehnte gemacht hat deswegen ist die
ukraine heute schon gedanklich politisch
teil unserer gemeinschaft unserer
wertegemeinschaft und für nächsten
donnerstag für den gipfel der jetzt
bevorsteht erwarte ich mir nicht nur
symbolik der staats und regierungschefs
bei dem kandidatenstatus sondern ich
erwarte mir auch dass wir den nächsten
kraftvollen schritt zur vertiefung der
europäischen union gehen wir wissen dass
die einstimmigkeit beispielsweise bei
der sanktionen denken sie an orban sein
veto nicht dauerhaft so bleiben kann und
wir müssen einen europäischen
verteidigung spiler aufbauen was
passiert denn wenn in zwei drei jahren
donald trump oder ein ein bruder im
geiste im weißen haus einzieht und nicht
mehr beiden dort regiert die europäer
müssten endlich in der lage sein und
selbst zu verteidigen diese fragen
müssen wir jetzt diskutieren und auch da
erwarte ich mir von berlin und paris
jetzt führung gebrauchen eine reform an
vertiefung der europäischen union
allerdings wird das was jetzt gerade
angesprochen haben ja schon seit jahren
gesagt dass wir eine reform der
europäischen union brauchen woran liegt
es denn dass die nicht so richtig voran
kommt dass es immer noch so ist dass
selbst länder die sie mit sanktionen
belegen wollen vor diesen ländern sie
sich quasi die zustimmung erst mal holen
müssen dazu was ja absurd ist
deshalb müssen wir den spieß umdrehen
bisher konnte in europa nur entschieden
werden wenn alle dabei waren und die
welt wartet nicht mehr auf unserer pr
bis wir uns wieder mal geeinigt haben
auf dieses einstimmigkeitsprinzip
deshalb wenn es nicht gelingt dass wir
länder wie ungarn mit viktor orban an
der spitze dafür gewinnen diesen
nächsten schritt der vertiefung zu gehen
beispielsweise die verteidigungs union
aufzubauen dann müssen wir diesen
schritt auch ohne orban gehen dann
müssen wir ihnen auch ohne diese länder
gehen das haben wir beim euro gemacht
auch da sind nicht alle staaten mit
dabei auch bei schengen haben wir das
gemacht dass wir schritte gemacht haben
ohne dass alle dabei waren und das ist
auch jetzt wieder notwendig ich möchte
nicht mehr auf den langsamsten warten
müssen europa muss jetzt kraft haben und
vorangehen und des muss olaf scholz
leisten bisher erwartet sehr zögerlich
was war es berlin gehört haben jetzt
muss berlin führen weber kann die eu in
ihrer derzeitigen verfasstheit in ihren
derzeitigen strukturen länder wie auf
dem westbalkan wie moldau wie die
ukraine aufnehmen
in einem land wie die republik moldau
die zwischen der ukraine und rumänien
platziertes geografisch liegt das sind
vergleichsweise kleine länder wenn die
mitglied werden sind die kein problem in
anführungsstrichen für uns sie können
eine bereicherung sein voraussetzung ist
aber dass wir die inneren reformen
angehen wenn jedes land dann weiterhin
blockieren kann dann laufen wir in das
risiko ein dass dieses europa nicht mehr
handlungsfähig ist und wer den blick
etwas weiter richtung china richtung
taiwan richtung afrika die großen fragen
die auf uns zukommen die jetzt im blick
etwas weitet der muss verstehen dass die
heutige europäische union nicht fit ist
wir sind nackt in der welt von stürmen
und wir müssen uns jetzt endlich an
gleiten und fit machen für die aufgaben
der nächsten den nächsten jahren nackt
in der welt von sturm sagt manfred weber
der chef der konservativen evp-fraktion
im europäischen parlament helvar danke
für das gespräch heute abend
ich bedanke mich
so und hier in der sendung schauen wir
jetzt auf den sportler und auf einen
gewinner zum dritten mal in folge haben
sie es geschafft alba berlin ist erneut
deutscher basketball meister die
berliner setzten sich deutlich gegen den
fc bayern münchen durch und siegten mit
96 zu 81 es ist das erste mal dass alba
berlin sich den meistertitel holt
in der formel 1 hat weltmeister max
verstappen den großen preis von kanada
für sich entschieden dicht gefolgt von
ferrari pilot carlos sainz mit
schumacher der auf die ersten formel 1
punkt seiner karriere gehofft hatte
schied wegen eines defekts am fahrzeug
frühzeitig aus zum tennis es ist eine
klatsche für den weltranglisten-ersten
daniel medwedew hat beim tennis
rasenturnier in halle überraschend das
finale gegen den polen hubert hohe cash
verloren dieser besiegte den klagen
favorit in zwei sätzen mit 6 1 und 6 zu
in genau einer woche kommt diese sendung
hier live vom g7 gipfel in den
bayerischen bergen aber auch davor wird
noch einiges passieren
hier ist der heute journal ausblick von
scarlett sternberg
[Musik]
wie sehen industriestandorte der zukunft
aus und wie mit wirtschaftskrisen
umgehen zum tag der industrie werden
sich politik wirtschaft und wissenschaft
ab montag in berlin drängenden fragen
widmen
die internationale luft und
raumfahrtausstellung ila wird am
dienstag ihre pforten in berlin öffnen
die größte luftfahrtmesse in europa soll
das erste mal nach zwei jahren wieder im
präsent stattfinden im programm einiges
an militärgerät und flugvorführungen des
eurofighters
am mittwoch wird der bundeskanzler eine
regierungserklärung abgeben vor dem eu
gipfel ende dieser woche geht es unter
anderem um die eu-beitrittsperspektive
mehrerer staaten
ab donnerstag befassen sich die
europäischen staats und regierungschefs
mit dem kandidatenstatus der ukraine ein
teil der eu länder ist noch skeptisch
der schritt zu einem kandidaten status
hat vor allem symbolwirkung
die linke wird ab freitag auf ihrem
parteitag ihren gesamten vorstand wählen
vorgesehen ist erneut eine doppelspitze
auch die bisherige vorsitzende janine
wissler kandidiert
und was uns nach diesem hitze wochenende
beim wetter erwartet die aussichten im
nordosten und in der mitte gibt es
morgen schauer im süden bilden sich am
nachmittag einzelne gewitter teils mit
hagel und starkregen dabei werden 17 bis
24 grad erreicht im süden 24 bis 33 grad
die kommenden tage bringen viel sonne
nur im süden und südwesten zeitweise
auch regenschauer und gewitter die
höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen 19
und 32 grad
und das war unsere welt an diesem
sonntag vielen dank dass sie dabei waren
ihm jetzt noch einen angenehmen abend
bis morgen
[Musik]